you are probably familiar with the
notion of a number line where we can
take a number and associated with a
point on the number line so for example
the number two I would go I would start
at zero and go one two to the right and
I would end up right over there
what we're going to do in this video is
think about how do we take two numbers
and associate them with a point on a
plane like this so for example you might
have the two numbers three comma five
how does that or how can these two
numbers be represented as a point on the
plane or how can these tell you where a
point on the plane is so let's first get
a little bit of terminology out of the
way so what we have here this is often
known as our coordinate plane these two
numbers you could view as our
coordinates let me write this down these
are coordinates these black lines are
known as the axes each one is an axis
and the one that goes left right here
this is known as the x-axis orts
typically known as the x axis in the
future it might be called other things
and the one that goes up down in the
vertical direction this is typically
known as the y axis as you go further in
math we might call it other things but
most of the time it's going to be called
the y axis so how does three comma five
how do these coordinates specify a point
on this plane well the way that we
typically work it through the standard
way that people will interpret these
points it'll say alright this first
coordinate this is our x coordinate this
is our x coordinate you can view it as
how far do we move to the right along
the x axis so what you would do is you'd
say all right I'm going to start right
here where my axes intersect and I'm
going to go 3 to the right 1 2 3 so my x
coordinate says alright my point is
going to be
is going to be this far to the right
this far the right so it's going to be
somewhere on this vertical line this
dotted line that I'm showing everything
on this vertical line has an x
coordinate of 3 now what's the y
coordinate or I know I should state the
second number right over here this is
the y coordinate y coordinate this tells
us how far do we move up so one way to
think about you could start back at
where the axes intersect this point is
actually called the origin let me write
that down that is the origin and so
starting at the origin move 5 up 1 2 3 4
5 so everything on this horizontal line
that I'm drawing has a y-coordinate of 5
so what point uniquely has both an x
coordinate of 3 and a y coordinate of 5
well you can see where those two lines
intersect right over here actually we do
that same blue color that I wrote the
coordinates in so this point right over
here it has an x coordinate of 3 and it
has a y coordinate of 5 that is the
point 3 comma 5 now what is the
coordinates of the origin well the
origin is 0 to the right of the origin
and it's also 0 above the origin so the
coordinates there the x coordinate is 0
the y coordinate is also 0 let's do a
few more examples so let's say that I
wanted to plot the point 2 comma 5 why
don't you pause this let me use a
different number 2 comma 4 why don't you
pause this video and think about where
that point would be on this coordinate
plane
alright let's do it together so the
first number is going to be our x
coordinate it tells us how far do we
move to the right so we move to to the
right and then our second number says
how far do we move up so let's first
we're going to move to to the right and
then we are going to move 4 up so you
could say 1 2 to the right and then 1 2
3 4
right over there this right over here is
the point 2 comma 4 notice its
x-coordinate how far to the right of the
origin it is that is 2 and its
y-coordinate how far above the origin is
that is 4 now let's go the other way
around
let's say that I were to give you if I
were to give you this point right over
here what would its coordinates be pause
the video and try to figure that out all
right well we know it's going to be two
numbers so I'll do something comma
something
now the first something that's going to
be our x-coordinate you could think of
it what what point on the x-axis are we
above you could think about how far to
the right of the origin we are and you
can see that your x coordinate right
over here is if we just drop a vertical
line straight down from that point it
hits the x-axis at four so that is for
another way to think about it we're one
two three four to the right of the
y-axis
now how high are we how high above the
x-axis are we well we're one above the
x-axis so this is going to be 4 comma
one another way to think about it if you
just take a line and you go straight to
the left you're going to hit the y-axis
at the one right over here so the
coordinates here are 4 comma 1 now just
so we don't get confusing when you first
learn this the main point of confusion
is remembering that okay the first
number is the x-coordinate the second
number is the y-coordinate 1 comma 4
would be a different point 1 comma 4
would be okay 1 in the x-direction and
then or in the y-direction
so this is 1 comma 4 over here so it's
very important to realize that the
standard way of interpreting these
numbers is that the first one says how
far do you move to the right of the
origin or how far do you move along the
x axis or where are you on the x axis
and the second number is how far do you
move in the vertical direction or where
are you relative to the Y or
where are or where are you in in in the
vertical direction